hello everyone welcome today to today's
live broadcast access key technologies
to accelerate genetic testing in your
laboratory I'm Rupert Yip of Nitara and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational webinar series presented by
lab roots and sponsored by natera natera
is a market leader in women's
reproductive genetics testing the
terrace complex technologies has been
proven clinically and commercially in
the prenatal testing space and the
company is actively researching its
applications in the liquid biopsy space
for developing products with oncology /
applications since 2009 the Terra has
launched seven molecular diagnostic
tests many of which are available
through major health plans accounting
for more than 140 million covered lives
in the United States the company's own
robust laboratory processes thousands of
genetic tests per month for more
information please visit natera com we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the screen by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical questions viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on support button at the top of
your presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker Samuel silk Sam received
his master's in science in bio
engineering from the university of
california san diego in la jolla
california subsequently he has health
scientific support positions at thermo
Fisher and fluid I'm working with
customers for a wide variety of
industries currently Sam is a field
application scientist with natera
providing technical assistance worldwide
to labs that are implementing natera
technology to offer genetic testing
including ni peachy to better craft the
presentation today we'd like to pull the
audience with a few questions how would
you describe the size of your lab is it
one to two people 3 2 20 people 20 1 250
people or more than 50 people select one
of these and click Submit
few more seconds
alright the next question
all right I see that most people are 3
220 and mix of folks that are
organizations that are more than 50
people excellent let's move on to the
next question
what type of affiliation is your lab are
you affiliated with an academic core lab
an academic research lab commercial
testing lab or a hospital lab will
provide about 10 to 15 seconds for folks
to answer this question and then we'll
share the results
okay all right majority commercial
testing lab excellent with a good
representation of academic research labs
excellent the next question please rank
in order of importance for an ni PD test
when you're considering an NR PP test do
you consider clinical performance number
and quality of scientific publications
or ease of use minimal hands-on time is
the most important factor when
considering an ni PT test
alright well it's no surprise to your
clinical performance is a minimum but it
does look like some people are
interested in something that is easy to
use as well alright next question what
level of Byron Byron firm attics
expertise do you have in your
organization none somewhat limited
moderately capable level or team of
expert buyer for miss Maddocks staff
okay we've got a pretty broad mix of
folks all right so without further ado
now turn it over to Samuel stuff for his
presentation access key technology to
accelerate genetic testing in your lab
Thank You Rupert hi everyone thank you
very much for joining the terrace
webinar today my name is Samuel sook a
field application scientist with nasarah
and it's my privilege to be presenting
to you today so to begin I'm going to
introduce our company what we do and
provide an overview of genetic testing
with respect to ipt this will then lead
us into our unique product offering
consolation so who who is natera natera
was founded in 2004 by dr. Matt
Rabinowitz who comes from a background
in engineering signal processing and
informatics dr. Rabinowitz has built a
team of world-class scientists
geneticists and by imitations to deliver
the world's most complex qualitative
method for the detection and
differentiation of fetal DNA from
maternal DNA this method is the only
method available in the US market that
can read reliably differentiate the
mother's DNA from fetal DNA for genetic
genetic abnormality risk assessment this
powerful new technology has proven so
popular and successful clinically that
despite being last ni PT technology to
market it has become the market leader
in the US
for the last six years the terrorist
scientists and engineers have been busy
innovating women's reproductive genetics
an unprecedented rate of almost one new
product per year natera has launched
highly accurate hi clinical performance
tests for a number of different products
including pre-implantation genetic
testing miscarriage testing paternity
testing carrier screening which screens
it for up to two hundred seventy four
disease conditions our market-leading ni
PT test panorama that includes screening
from microdeletions scalable
bioinformatics powered by our
constellation software and coming soon
oncology screening applications via
blood draw while we started out in
women's reproductive genetics were
replying our innovative snip based
technology to identify heterogeneous
tumor DNA that circulates in the blood
of early-stage cancer patients we
believe our advanced technology is
powerful enough to detect tumors with
greater sensitivity and specificity over
current technologies while we are a
strong player in the US natera already
has a worldwide presence of over 60
countries to date and we're still
expanding at a rapid pace so the
completion of the Human Genome Project
ushered in a new era in genetic testing
and with the rapid decline of the cost
of sequencing more labs are now able to
offer genetic testing many of today's
hospital and reference laps started out
doing biochemical tests panels and still
analyze numerous samples using
biochemical methods but because of this
stochastic nature of enzymes many of
these tests have low sensitivity
specificity and positive predictive
values further these methods can
sometimes be time-consuming especially
if they require a growth phase to
generate
sample amniocentesis for example
requires a growth phase to accumulate
enough genetic material for analysis and
unlike traditional biochemical tests
genetic tests can be performed much
faster and with greater precision and as
genetic tests become more prevalent and
have positive health economics more
private and public payers are began
beginning to reimburse for such tests
however the decision to move into
genetic testing is isn't always so
simple it's fraught with it's probably
several challenges for example the
financial challenges of high cost of
capital equipment purchases and
maintenance of these equipment complex
workflow that can be daunting to
next-gen sequencing novices and highly
complex bioinformatics that require high
performance computer resources as well
as by automatic skills and finally to
make a business case work you need to
identify a source of revenue private
public insurance patient out of pocket
for for your new genetic testing service
of all the genetic tests that came as
the genetic conditions that can be
tested for an ipt genetic testing is an
ideal first genetic test to implement in
a lab that's considering offering
genetic testing and ni PT is an ideal
first genetic test because of several
reasons there's a very large market for
such tests and while relatively new ni
PT is already a proven technology that
had an shoulder superior to the
traditional maternal serum screening
method unlike sequencing interpreting
entire human genomes worth of data the
bond informatics to NI PT is relatively
simple and finally mine many health
insurance companies and some national
healthcare systems are already
reimbursing for
ipt so many labs endeavoring into
genetic testing we'll start out with an
ipt for the reasons above and as they
get more and more familiar and
comfortable with it with this technology
they can start expanding into other
genetic testing applications such as in
ecology so I'd like to spend some time
to introduce you to some of the basics
about ni PT and background of existing
technologies so to start what what is ni
PT ni PT examines placental DNA also
also referred to as feel DNA in many
cases in a mother's bloodstream to
determine whether a developing baby is
at higher or lower risk for certain
chromosomal or sub chromosomal genetic
disorders these may be caused by entire
missing or extra chromosomes called
aneuploidies or small missing pieces of
chromosomes called micro deletions in a
simple non-invasive blood test from the
mother provides an accurate screen of
the baby's genetics as early as nine
weeks gestation ni PT is actually
offered by numerous companies using a
variety of techniques while while most
are using a method referred to as
accounting method natera uses a
different technology using snip based
targeted sequencing so what is different
between these two technologies and what
are the benefits of using snip based
targeted sequencing so in counting all
genetic material in the blood is
analyzed without differentiation between
what is maternal DNA and what is fetal
DNA in targeted sequencing carefully
selected snips on the chromosomes of
interests are analyzed which allows for
differentiation between the maternal DNA
and the fetal DNA and this is a very
important point to keep in mind and in
counting where one can't distinguish the
fetal signal the observed amount of DNA
is compared to the expected amount of
DNA for the chromosome of interests
which is then assessed against the
reference chromosome so for example in
the case of trisomy 21 the amount of
chromosome 21 is quantified against the
reference chromosome 3 which is
typically present at the normal two
copies so this results in a lower
sensitivity a lower field fractions
example of what such a quantification
might look like is shown on the graph on
the right where in the context of
maternal DNA represented in gray the
green represents the expected amount of
DNA for fetal diesem II and blue
represents the expected amount of DNA
for fetal trisomy a difference is in the
expected amounts of fetal DNA can be
used for analysis of the dye samee versa
trisomy of the chromosomes of interests
recall that in actuality since there is
no differentiation between feel and
maternal DNA we now represent the fetal
components and gray as well at higher
fetal fractions the difference is larger
becoming less and less discernible I
lower fetal fractions so as you can see
it becomes increasingly difficult to
discern the state of dicey versus
trisomy if there is no color coding as
is the case with the counting methods
unfortunately we don't know whether the
DNA is maternal or fetal and must rely
simply on the difference in quantity and
as such it's vitally important to
distinguish and report fetal fractions
along with any an employee determination
not doing so is is akin to a trial
witness claiming identification of a
suspect without indication of how foggy
the conditions were when you saw the
suspect
before venturing into what the
contrasting technology is I'd like to
briefly describe what snips or single
nucleotide polymorphisms are and the
taro we use a snip based technology
versus accounting method as previously
discussed the snips are single base pair
differences that occur as normal
variations between different people all
those say 99 percent of everyone's DNA
is the same one percent can be different
we focus on that one percent of the DNA
that can in fact be different at some of
these points mom and baby will be the
same but as some of these points they
will be different and we use over 13,000
of these points where they are different
to determine a fetal DNA pattern within
the month maternal blood Detert the
determine deploy d of the chromosomes of
interest before getting into the
specifics of how snip based are
targeting targeted ticks sorry targeted
sequencing works first a little bit of
background humans normally have two
copies of each chromosome for a total of
forty-six we target snips on chromosomes
of interest namely 13 18 21 and the sex
chromosomes to study their fatal signal
for simplicity let's look at a single
pair of chromosomes let's let's say
chromosome 21 at a snip locus or
position each chromosome has one of two
nucleotide possibilities also known as
an allele let's label these generically
as allele a and allele be and just keep
in mind that a doesn't refer to the
adenine nucleotide base it's simply a
generic filler to represent an allele
and at each snip position we have we can
have 2 a's we can have 1a or 1b or we
can have 2 b's and across the chromosome
we analyze many thousands of snips we're
at each position we can determine
allelic state whether it be 2 a's 2 b's
or 1a and 1b now looking at this entire
chromosome of the unit for the purposes
of illustration we can turn it onto its
side and in a normal genome at each
position we will have one hundred
percent allele a 50-percent allele a or
zero percent a now plotting this out as
a ratio of a with respect to the
position on the chromosome we can have
we can have for these three snips that
are displayed here just three dots at
one hundred percent fifty percent and
and a zero percent so looking at the
center snip of this chromosome it's
fifty percent a and let's say this let's
say the genome now has a small
contribution from another individual the
fetus and if the fetus at this position
also has fifty percent a that is it
inherited 1a and 1b the plotted point
looks exactly the same if the fetus
inherited an a from the mother and
another and another a from the father
then the ratio of a is now slightly
higher due to the small fetal
contribution of additional a if the
fetus inherited a B from the mother and
the B from the father
then now the ratio of a is slightly
lower due to the small fetal
contribution of be in other words
there's a little less a in that case so
now we can do this for each each
position on the chromosome and end up
with a banding pattern due to the fatal
signal and we can now distinctly
calculate what what is commonly known as
the fetal fraction within the context of
maternal DNA so using the information
from the totality of snips that were
assessing we can generate what we call
an allele frequency plot 0% fetal
fraction or no pregnancy well as three
bands one at allele one and what a
hundred percent a one at fifty percent a
and one a 0% a and as as we introduce
the fetus we can see a distinct banding
pattern whose distance depends on the
fetal fraction so as you can see from
the band distances increases the fuel's
fetal fraction increases in this example
at twelve percent fetal fraction the
fetal band start to appear with a band
segregating further out at higher at
higher fetal fractions and this and in
this graph we show a 26-percent field
fraction the maternal and fetal genotype
combinations for each band is known and
shown on the brackets the right of the
plot now to illustrate what it tries to
be would look like while of course we
use algorithms to make these assessments
we can also visualize it easily on a
high field fraction sample as shown here
so to give you a visual example the
normal three band allele ratio pattern
then manifests as a district a discreet
banding pattern due to the additional
contribution to the allele ratio by the
third chromosome so on the left here is
an example of a dice new pattern with a
different pattern that's shown on the
right for 4am trisomy so using this knit
based technology to distinguish maternal
and fetal genotypes allows us to study
CF DNA isolated from maternal blood that
contains both the maternal and fetal CF
DNA we can then generate accurate fetal
fraction and any booty calls by
analyzing the snip ratio patterns via
the advanced by automatic software the
advanced bio informatics within our
software and this methodology also
manifests in clinical advantages
resulting in lower false positive and
negative rates relative to other
technologies our clinical accuracy is
displayed in these graphs as aggregate
data from various validation studies
that span over 30,000 patient samples
it's important to note that the data
shown here is for all the employees of
interest and a lot of the data you'll
see from various counting method
companies will only show data for
certain conditions like trisomy 21
however showing data for only certain
trisomies is misleading because the
counting method traditionally has had
issues with any place other than 21 it's
also important to note that the
methodology for these studies was not
uniform more specifically some studies
obtained confirmation of truth in all
cases while others only solicited
outcomes and high-risk calls
another important point is that a higher
call rate is not necessarily better one
might conclude that a higher call rate
means higher call success rate but
that's not necessarily the case just as
a boy who cries wolf all the time is
going to lose trust if some of his calls
or false positives a test that
constantly provides calls without regard
to whether to calls or confidence or not
will lose credibility our blind cymatics
algorithms not only makes a call I'm
sorry our butter fur makes the algorithm
only makes a call when the results are
of high confidence for example we don't
call a result if the data is low
confidence or has a fetal fraction
that's too low some may interpret this
as a higher test failure rate but the
reality is that more discriminant test
calls means the lower false positives
and a greater trust in the calls and
this is clearly demonstrated by our
clinical superiority that was shown in
the previous slide since PPV is a is a
fraction of positive calls made that are
actually positive for the antibody of
interest it's a good indicator of
calling out the right answer compared to
the traditional first trimester
screening where ninety ninety seven
percent of women will get a false
positive and be referred unnecessarily
for an invasive testing our technology
will only result in around nine percent
for trisomy 21
now just say a high level view into what
our workflow looks like collected blood
undergoes standard centrifugation
technique for plasma isolation from
which CF DNA is extracted what we call
library preparation here is the
preparation of fragmented CF DNA to
undergo highly multiplex targeted snip
amplification of the of the over 13,000
different targets in a single reaction
we then barcode these samples to be able
to pool and sequence them where the bar
coding allows us did see multiplex the
sample after sequencing data analysis is
performed in the cloud through our
constellation software which generates
information needed for reporting those
who are implementing the workflow will
have aid from both the technical lab
aspects from our field applications team
and the software aspect from our fields
from our software applications team so
what does the natera offer the labs
interested in genetic testing for an ipt
natera has spent millions of dollars in
research development clinical validation
as well as a regulatory registration for
its advanced technology and is committed
to continually improving and innovating
genetic testing technologies natera has
made the decision to make these
technologies available to lab customers
who may be interested in using these
technologies to kick start or extend
their genetic testing capabilities and
the terrorist technology offering
includes the bioinformatics software
platform the proprietary reagents and
support from our applications and in our
support team which allows laps to easily
develop validate and clinically offer
genome genomics assays namely the
panorama saya presence with future
applications in liquid biopsy for cancer
screening using the same constellation
software platform
an incorporation of constellation will
allow the lab to grow their testing
options alongside natera is increasing
portfolio we have readily available
reagents for library preparation that
streamlines CF DNA preparation workflow
as well as for the multiplex pcr for
simple targeted amplification as if of
the over 13,000 snip targets within a
single well per sample the constellation
bioinformatics platform accelerates
genetic testing by combining innovative
science with scalable bioinformatics for
genomics labs that are looking into to
enter or expand genetic testing
constellation powers highly accurate
proven science that can quickly deliver
answers with confidence in fact this
platform houses the same algorithms used
by the terrorists CLIA facility and
offers many other benefits including
HIPAA compliance basic internet
requirements and foundation for
implementing future genetic tests and
last but not least we have a dedicated
field applications and software
application support teams to aid with
any questions provide guidance and offer
troubleshooting assistance so that
concludes the presentation portion thank
you everyone for joining me today now
I'm going to turn it over to Rupert to
see if we have any questions from the
audience thank you Sam for that
informative presentation for more
information on this webinar and some of
the content that Sam was provided please
click on the link section to review or
download materials now before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing in the Q&A
box which
be found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can so the first
question how is your n IPP technology
different compared to other n ipt
technology so other other technologies
use use counting where genetic material
in the blood is is analyzed for
chromosomal abnormalities without
differentiation between what's maternal
and what is fetal DNA in our technology
carefully selected snips are sequenced
and this allows us to differentiate
between maternal and fetal DNA and
assess chromosomal abnormalities this
provides us a unique capability to
determine fetal fractions and improve
clinical performance great the next
question is what does it mean when you
say you can differentiate between mother
and baby DNA don't all ni PT do this so
so not not all technologies have this
capability to differentiate the mom and
baby is DNA for assessment of genetic
abnormalities in the case of counting
there's note there is no clearly
discreet way to differentiate the mother
in baby's DNA now using snips though we
can tell the baby apart from the mother
due to differences in the inherited
snips we can also determine how much
difference there is which allows us to
calculate the fetal fraction thank you
the next question is is your reagent kit
or bioinformatics ze mark yeah yes so we
offer a CF DNA library preparation kit a
multiplex pcr kit and software cloud
cloud platform that are all see a marked
excellent our next question is where in
the world is your technology available
for licensing
so we'll we'll be happy to work with you
to discuss availability of licensing at
your location please contact us after
the webinar if you're interested and we
we will be happy to get in touch with
you to discuss further you can also find
contact information in the link section
on your screen and we definitely look
forward to speaking with you about that
exam the next question is what is the
process for bringing in your technology
to our lab so once once all the
agreements are in place our scientific
and software applications team will work
very closely with you to help you obtain
more information training guidance with
implementation and all for
troubleshooting as needed and that's the
high-level overview and we can discuss
in more detail if you'd like to contact
us thanks Sam the next question is how
is the fetal DNA distinguished from
mother DNA is there a target sequence
that fetal DNA has that the mother DNA
doesn't have good question the the fetal
DNA can be distinguished because we're
targeting we're targeting polymorphisms
in the in the genome and at these
locations that we amplify using our
highly multiplex PCR depending on what
the fetus is inheriting from the mom and
the dad we can we can see if the
genotype is different from the month the
background mother's DNA that this DNA is
is the fetus so this is how we can
differentiate using snips what is what
is fetus
what is the mom thanks Sam there were
several questions asking this which NGS
platform is our technology on so at the
moment we we use a luminous sequencers
we have we have some efforts in
validating other platforms as well for
more information I would say you know
feel free to contact us and we're happy
to talk with you about that exam the
next question is do you provide on-site
training yes so we we can definitely
help provide training on site as needed
if troubleshooting assistance is needed
we can help with that as well so with
the with the implementation process we
have the technical team as well as the
software team who can also visit your
site and where we're there with you each
step of the way to help you through that
process excellent next question is how
does the system determine which tests
are non decisive is it based on how
clear and separate the allele bands from
the chromosome from the field DNA
contribution looks sorry I'm not sure
exactly what that question means what
good is a could you repeat that question
sure how does the system determine which
tests are non decisive I guess what he's
trying to ask is does the system
differentiate based on how clear and how
clearly the bands are separated
so with the with the snip thought that
I'd showed showed earlier we can
visually kind of estimate the fetal
fraction however our algorithms have our
software has algorithms that will
calculate this for for for you so
there's really no no no visual component
in stating what the fetal fraction is we
have algorithms to do that for us
however if if we were to look at the
snip plot we could visually estimate
what that is depending on how far the
band is away from the be maternal man I
hope that answers the question sure next
question is when will your technology be
available for licensing I guess so the
technology for ni PT is is available now
depending on your location you know we
would have to discuss we'd have to
discuss further with you so we have we
have a couple of emails here listed on
the on the screen and you can also check
the links and feel free to contact us
when we can discuss that discuss that in
more detail with you excellent the next
question is how did you choose the
13,000 snus that's a very good question
so first of all we we needed to choose
snips that are located on the
chromosomes of interest so we're looking
at snips on 13 18 21 and the sex
chromosomes the sectional isms are a
little different but for simplicity
there will say these are all snips when
the snips that we choose they have to
cover the length of the chromosome
just so we have a good idea of a good
picture of the entire chromosomes that
were that were interested in we also
have to choose sniffs that are that have
high minor allele frequencies so there's
a higher chance of difference between
the mom and the fetus though so that we
can actually make good determinations if
the baby's DNA is the same as the moms
DNA that is if the genotype that all of
these snips are the same then since
there's no difference we can't tell
between them however we've carefully
chosen these snips that have high minor
allele frequencies that is they have a
high chance that the genotypes are
different between the mom and the fetus
so that we have a very good idea and a
very good chance of actually determining
what's determining the difference
between the fetus and the mom excellent
um the next question is what annual
volume makes economic sense so this
depends on many factors and I think this
is a question that could best be
addressed probably by byte by sales and
we do have a sales team that can work
with you closely to to help work out
those numbers with you and again you can
contact us we can provide you with more
details about that great the next
question is does your technology
involves detecting carriers of
thalassemia using mini seek and analysis
using by automatic software to detect
new mutations the NI PT the is it does
not look for this so we have a set we
have a set panel that looks at certain
chromosomes
and we're looking at aunty booties with
extension of microdeletions as well as
for the mutation you're talking about it
may be covered in some of the other
products however I would say to get more
information about that please contact us
we would have to have someone with more
expertise in the other product lines to
help you with that question excellent
and we have time for just one more
question to distinguish which sniffs
belongs to mom or fetus wouldn't you
have to know the sequence of the mom
first yes and we know we can tell what
the moms genotype is at all of these
snips within within the blood so from
the plasma from which we isolate the
CFDA that contains that contains both
the maternal portion as well as the
fetal portion and we can determine what
is the maternal background and from
there we can also see what's different
and what's different would be what's
coming from the fetus so we do we do get
a picture of what the moms genotype is
at all of these snips and add the places
where they're different that's where we
can tell the the fetal genotype and
depending on how different they are well
the proportion of the fetal DNA to the
maternal DNA we can determine field
fraction so the signal coming for the
fetus and based on all these differences
all these snips that were interested in
we can determine chromosomal
abnormalities as well thanks Sam do the
time we won't have time to go through
all the questions and I encourage the
audience to follow us on social media
Facebook LinkedIn and Twitter where we
can answer all those questions there
you can follow us there so once again
I'd like to thank Sam for his
presentation and Sam I'd like they ask
if you have any final comments yeah yeah
thanks thanks Rupert and I'd like to add
that while matera has invested millions
of dollars in RMB in clinical trials and
we're at a point where we believe these
technologies are invaluable to to all
who may benefit and as such we're making
our technologies available to anyone who
is interested in bringing the most
advanced genetic testing technologies
and algorithms into their labs the
audience members can click on the links
on your screen to get more information
on how to act as the Terra technologies
and with that I'd like to conclude this
webinar and thank you very much to
everyone for joining us today thanks
that I'd also like to thank our sponsor
natera from making today's educational
webinar possible today's webinar will be
available for on-demand viewing through
six weeks from today you will receive an
email from lab roots alerting you when
this webinar will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event and until
then see you next time thank you and
goodbye